♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER:
It was a rainy morning.
We all went down
into our sanctuary space.
I turned around, and there was
the man with the gun.
OFFICER:
Shots fired, shots fired!
OFFICER 2:
They have an active shooter
in the building.
MICHELE ROSENTHAL:
We got a text that just said,
"Active shooter
at Tree of Life Synagogue."
OFFICER 2: Several persons
barricaded inside.
NURSE: Jerry and I looked
at each other.
Jerry's a doctor, I'm a nurse,
and thought that somehow
we could be helpful,
so we moved in the direction
of the gunfire.
OFFICER 2:
There's a great fear
among people that the culture
of White America
has been diminished.
These groups are emboldened,
they're empowered,
and they're vocal.
SPEAKER 2:
The days when synagogues
just leave their doors open,
I think those days are gone.
SPEAKER 3:
When you think about
what can come
of this sort of situation,
you need to think about
the values for which
the victims stood.
♪ Rest your head... ♪
Whether Jewish, or Catholic,
or Muslim,
everybody seemed touched
because this could happen
to them.
♪ The earth might shake
The winds may blow ♪
Because of misconceptions
about both of our communities,
a lot of people were surprised
to see the Muslim community
step up and help
the Jewish community.
Our religions are very similar.
Our values are similar.
♪ To raise a candle
In their names ♪
Parkland has been here.
The church in Charleston,
they were here.
ROSENTHAL:
When there's a shooting,
we text each other,
'cause you'll just know
what each other's feeling.
SPEAKER 3:
It's about how we can change
other people's lives
in a positive manner
because that is what
the victims would've wanted.
SPEAKER 4:
Their memories really are
a blessing for all of us...
and part of them continues
to live on within us.
♪ I'll hold you tight ♪
♪ Beneath the Tree of Life ♪